bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
l'historienne et spécialiste des
États-Unis nicole Bacharan qui publie
son livre de loin le plus personnel la
plus résistante de toutes c'est le titre
c'est chez Stock et c'est votre mère
Ginette guide on vous retracez le destin
bouleversant c'est un livre sur le
courage sur la liberté qui résonne avec
la guerre en Ukraine on va en parler on
est ensemble pendant une heure pour
décrypter l'actualité de ce mardi 24
janvier au sommaire ce soir les femmes
dans la réforme des retraites gagnantes
ou grandes perdantes Elizabeth borne a
martelé cet après-midi que non elle ne
seront pas pénalisées mais qu'en est-il
précisément le report de l'âge légal
va-t-il l'aider certaines générations de
femmes par rapport aux hommes c'est
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
nos invités avant de retrouver bien sûr
nos affranchis pour leur partie prix
leur carte blanche aux alentours de
20h15 et puis le bourbon Express ce soir
ce référendum que veut déclenchez les
opposants à la retraite à l'Assemblée on
verra ça avec Elsa mon bengaba voilà
vous savez tout Nicole Bachard vous êtes
prête je suis favorable on y va
le gouvernement le gouvernement se
servirait-il des femmes pour passer des
mesures injustes et bien c'est la petite
musique qui monte sur la réforme des
retraites on va essayer de faire le
point sur le vrai du faux ce soir
gagnante ou perdante quelle génération
précisément dans cette réforme bonsoir
Benoît mournet bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes députés renaissance
des Hautes-Pyrénées trois femmes sur ce
plateau pour pour débattre bonsoir
Sandrine Rousseau merci d'être là député
écologiste de Paris bonsoir Céline
Verzeletti bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes secrétaire confédéral de la CGT et
bonsoir Fanny Guy nochet bonsoir visage
familier de cette émission vous êtes
journaliste économique à France Info et
à la tribune d'ailleurs vous signez pour
la tribune un papier très complet sur le
sujet aujourd'hui nicole Bacharan
j'imagine que le sujet vous concerne on
a tous concerné n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous le souhaitez on a
besoin de planter le décor avec la miss
Stéphane blackovski pour commencer alors
si j'ai bien compris ce serait peut-être
la double peine pour les femmes je n'ose
y croire il a deux secondes pour y
répondre le chrono de la côte tout de
suite
et on se retourne pour vous accueillir
comme chaque soir Stéphane bonsoir
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir aussi monsieur
Bournay mais avant tout bonsoir à toutes
alors les femmes dans cette réforme et
ben là ce soir je suis excusez-moi
j'appelle ma salive mais à d'autres
doigts d'être scandalisé je suis pas
tout à fait scandalisé mais franchement
pas loin parce que on est quand même à
la veille de la journée de lutte
nationale contre le sexisme et qu'est-ce
qu'on apprend aujourd'hui que la réforme
des retraites sera deux fois pèsera deux
fois plus sur les femmes que sur les
hommes donc là vous comprenez ma
réaction alors évidemment je suis
journaliste donc j'ai un petit penchant
pour les formules chocs mais quand je me
dis que les femmes vont être pénalisées
deux fois plus que les hommes c'est pas
moi c'est le gouvernement qui le dit
regardez le gouvernement est tenu de
fournir une étude d'impact c'est à dire
d'expliquer aux députés un peu quelles
sont les conséquences de la réforme et
donc si on prend les cas des personnes
nées en 1980 au cas où la réforme
passerait on voit bien qu'ils vont
devoir travailler plus longtemps qu'il
soit homme ou femme en revanche dans le
détail les hommes eux vont devoir pareil
quatre mois de plus et les femmes huit
mois de plus donc le double c'est
exactement ce que je vous disais donc
forcément
dans ce dossier là
ça passe mal mais le gouvernement
lui-même le reconnait il dit non mais il
y a pas de problème on reconnaît le
dossier Franck Riester était hier à
audition publique l'émission des chaînes
parlementaire et le temps il reconnaît
oui les femmes sont pénalisés par le
report de l'âge légal donc pas la peine
d'avoir des formules shop de
journalistes il l'a voulu même bon en
même temps on a du mal à suivre la
communication du Gouvernement sur ce
sujet je sais pas c'est peut-être de la
pédagogie moderne c'est à dire on
reconnaît que la réforme est injuste
pour gagner la confiance des gens en
leur prouvant qu'on est honnête bon à
mon avis ça tient moyen
cela dit Franck ressemble n'est pas
resté là il a dû se rendre compte qu'il
se tirait une balle blanquier donc il a
voulu donner une explication voilà
pourquoi les femmes étaient plus
pénalisées le problème c'est que c'est
un peu technique on l'écoute c'est très
technique mais avec le report de l'âge
le les trimestres par enfant ne jouent
pas sur le report de l'âge il joue sur
la durée de cotisation pour autant on va
expliquer une femme par exemple pour
répartir à 62 ans admettons avec les
trimestres qu'elle aura gagné avec ses
enfants mais comme il y a un âge légal à
64 ans
qui a permis à peu de comprendre de quoi
en parler donc pour résumer en fait
c'est-à-dire que les femmes qui vont
obtenu leur 43 à nuité mais qui n'ont
pas encore atteint l'âge légal elles ne
peuvent pas partir elles doivent
attendre travailler plus longtemps donc
certes les femmes sont pénalisées
notamment parce que les annuités
gagnaient avec les enfants du coup sont
assez vanouissent mais pour lancer un
peu le débat je voudrais quand même
rappeler que une femme cadre elle vit en
moyenne en espérance de vie 10 ans de
plus qu'un ouvrier donc est-ce que c'est
vraiment les femmes qui sont visées sans
vouloir me faire 12 marxiste que je ne
suis je me demande si en fait on
retrouve pas le défaut de cette réforme
qui cible les catégories les plus
modestes donc forcément comme les femmes
ont des carrières plus hachées et
qu'elles gagnent en moyenne moins que
les hommes elle se trouve pénalisée donc
je vais vous laisser les battre de ce
point-là simplement par faire plein
notamment pour le gouvernement on va pas
rester sur les explications un peu
courtes de Frank Riester on va plutôt
donner la parole à Isabelle Bank qui
était cet après-midi à l'Assemblée qui a
dû répondre aux questions écoute
l'augmentation moyenne des petites
pensions sera deux fois plus élevée pour
elle que pour les hommes j'ajoute que
les femmes bénéficieront de meilleures
pensions de fait la réforme contribuera
à réduire l'écart de pension entre les
hommes et les femmes donc je résume d'un
côté français Esther dire que les femmes
vont travailler plus de l'autre et
diabète bornier qu'elles vont gagner
plus donc on arrive à travailler plus
pour gagner plus vous rajeunit pas c'est
quand même 2007 peut-être que enfin je
veux pas compliquer le débat mais
peut-être que en 15 ans le rapport au
travail a un peu changé je sais pas
c'est vrai que c'est technique mais en
même temps c'est extrêmement politique
on va commencer par cette étude d'impact
qui a jeté le trouble jusque dans les
rangs on le voit du ministre en charge
des relations avec les parlements c'est
pas rien quand même je suis une femme je
suis né en 1972 j'ai des enfants je vais
travailler 9 mois de plus alors que les
hommes c'est seulement 5 qu'est-ce que
vous avez à répondre à ça bonsoir et
merci nous on est occasion d'avoir un
débat un peu approfondie pour aller
justement au-delà des des formules cette
réforme d'abord juste d'un mot si vous
me permettez la justice c'est une
justice entre les générations ceux qui
travaillent cotisant pour ceux qui sont
à la retraite et on veut préserver cette
chaîne de solidarité entre les
générations l'âge moyen de départ pour
les femmes contre 5 pour les hommes pour
la génération 70 dans le droit actuel
vous le savez alors les femmes depuis
2010 en fait les parents
ont ce qu'on appelle une majoration de
la durée d'assurance quand vous avez
trois enfants vous avez 10% de
majoration de pension et vous avez droit
à 8 trimestres par enfant donc par
exemple si vous avez deux enfants
aujourd'hui c'est pas 42 années que vous
cotisez ces 38 donc la cette durée
d'assurance joue sur la durée sur les 43
ans quand le l'âge légal est décalé
mécaniquement forcément le temps de
durée d'assurance pour aller à l'âge
légal et est plus court et donc on va
avoir moins qu'aujourd'hui les faits qui
est que les femmes partent avant l'âge
légal vous reconnaissez qu'aujourd'hui
les fameux trimestres les 8 trimestres
par enfant les 8 efface les 8 trimestres
d'impact sur le temps long pour la
génération 1961 aujourd'hui l'écart de
pension entre les hommes et les défenses
mais elle est de 30%. à l'issue de la
réforme pour la génération 80 elle sera
de 18 donc progressivement le temps à la
retraite devient convergent entre les
hommes et les femmes l'écart de pension
se réduit et j'ajoute la première
ministre la liste après-midi que les
minimum de pension ça va bénéficier on
va faire ça dans l'ordre parce que ces
techniques et j'aimerais bien que ceux
qui nous regardent puisse prendre
quelque chose on va rester sur cette
histoire d'étude d'un pacte Sandrine
Rousseau vous l'aviez vous l'aviez vu ce
point vous franchement et bien sûr parce
que en fait les les femmes bénéficient
d'un report pour les enfants pourquoi
pourquoi parce que les maternités sont
des moments où ça casse les carrières en
fait dans les parcours des femmes et
donc c'était une forme de compensation
de la discrimination subie sur le acquis
d'office 8 par enfant aujourd'hui voilà
on y revient pas dès qu'on décale il y a
des effets de l'âge de la retraite et
ben évidemment cet effet là ça mendrit
donc évidemment ce sont les femmes qui
vont être les premières impactées par
cette par cette réforme des retraites et
moi qui suis né en 72 je rentre
exactement dans le dans le cas que vous
mais moi ce qui me fascine c'est
l'espèce d'explication du gouvernement
ou alors vous comprenez que si on
diminue ça et si on augmente ça alors en
fait non enfin si l'étude d'impact le
dit c'est que c'est vrai voilà donc
c'est l'étude d'impact fournit par le
gouvernement à la pluie de sa loi oui
les femmes vont pâtir de cette réforme
premièrement deuxième argument quand
vous dites la génération 80 sera
différente de la génération 60 oui parce
que les inégalités femmes se sont
réduites sur le marché du travail donc
la réalité c'est que ça n'est pas la
réforme qui réduit les choses ce sont
les inégalités sur le marché du travail
et en l'occurrence là-dessus il y a
quand même encore beaucoup à faire
puisque je rappelle que les femmes
gagnent 22% de moins que les hommes au
cours de leur carrière quand elles
travaillent et que en retraite en
retraite les hommes gagnent 67% de plus
que les femmes je répète ce chiffre à la
que les femmes ou est-ce qu'il est enfin
dans quelle tête malade il y a eu l'idée
de pénaliser les femmes en plus vraiment
où est-ce qu'on est alors Fanny
guynochet il faut qu'on essaye de voilà
de bien démêler les questions sur cette
étude d'impact aujourd'hui on est des
facto avec cette réforme pénalisé je dis
on parce que je suis une femme et je
suis pas loin d'être dans la génération
j'y suis même entre 70 et 80 si on
regarde bien les tunes d'impact je vais
faire un cas concret tout simple vous
avez Nathalie Marc né en 75 il se sont
rencontrés pendant leurs études ils ont
commencé à travailler dans le privé à 23
ans et ils font une carrière
identique ils ont deux enfants jusque là
tout va bien dans le système actuel Marc
doit attendre 66 ans pour faire valoir
puisqu'il y a la durée de cotisation qui
joue pour pouvoir partir à la retraite à
taux plein voilà dans le système actuel
Nathalie qui a eu donc deux enfants
écailles une bonification puisque c'est
8 trimestres par enfant elle bah si vous
faites le calcul elle a 4 ans où elle
peut non pas partir à suffisant comme
marque elle peut partir elle a 62 ans et
c'est l'âge légal donc elle part à 62
ans demain si vous prenez la même
Nathalie et le même marque né en 75 et
bien avec le report de l'âge qui est
aujourd'hui à 64 ans et bien vous voyez
bien que pour Marc sang ne va rien
changer mais pour Nathalie et bien de 62
il faudra qu'elle fasse qu'elle
travaille jusqu'à 64 je suis passé par
cet exemple là parce que c'est très
clair merci de se cet effort de
pédagogie ce que montre l'étude d'un
pack alors ça va croissant là on prend
l'exemple de 75 mais c'est encore pire
pour la génération 80 les titres
d'impact elle est très clair et elle
monte qu'au sein d'une même génération
entre les hommes et les femmes entre les
femmes qui ont eu des enfants puisque là
vraiment c'est des avantages familiaux
on pourrait peut-être dire un rattrapage
familial donc entre les hommes et les
femmes qui ont eu des enfants qui sont
le même âge et bien il y a une
différence voilà
aujourd'hui cette différence elle existe
mais elle se creuse quelque part tout le
monde va travailler plus mais
effectivement les femmes du coup se
trouvent les ça touche essentiellement
les générations 70 80 évidemment que
plus on va aller et certainement les
générations suivantes nos filles nos
petites filles elles les cartes se
diminuera mais en l'état ce que montre
l'étude d'impact du gouvernement c'est
se différencier au sein d'une même
génération entre des hommes et des
femmes et c'est vrai que là où c'est
compliqué à justifier même si les
chiffres sont têtus et que c'est
majorations en tout cas cette
bonification a été mis en place parce
que les femmes ont des carrières plus
hachées alors elle les avait déjà dans
les années 50 c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui elles ont des pensions
beaucoup plus bases et elle les avait
quand même dans les années celles qui
sont nées dans les années 70 ou les
années 80 que on sait bien que l'égalité
homme-femme pour les générations donc
c'est des femmes qui ont 45 ans elles
ont souvent eu des arrêts dans leur
carrière qui a pesé sur les salaires et
qui se reportent sur les pensions et
c'est vrai que juste pour terminer
l'argument du gouvernement qui dit que
les pensions vont s'améliorer avec la
réforme elles vont effectivement l'étude
d'impact le montre elles vont
effectivement s'améliorer notamment pour
les femmes plus âgées qui ont eu des
petites pensions parce que deux merci la
société change un peu c'est ça la
réforme elles vont et il fait gagner
essentiellement s'améliorer parce que
les femmes vont travailler plus
longtemps qu'elles ont plus diplômés et
qu'elles ont quand même un meilleur
salaire que nos générations faciles de
répondre à ça c'est un placable la
démonstration de famille alors c'est
très intéressant vous avez cité l'étude
d'impact et effectivement la retraite
c'est pour ça aussi que c'est un sujet
aussi sensible c'est qu'il nous renvoie
notre rapport au travail il renvoie
autant qui autant qui passent autant
qu'il reste si on peut dire mais les
inégalités qui existent dans le monde du
travail les inégalités hommes femmes les
inégalités entre professions elles se
retrouvent dans la retraite le système
de retraite peut pas corriger toutes les
inégalités de la vie professionnelle il
les corrige il les corrige
ce que je veux dire juste sur pour être
complet sur les femmes les femmes
effectivement aujourd'hui ont des
carrières plus hachées sont sur des en
moyenne des niveaux de revenus
inférieurs donc elles vont bénéficier à
plein de la revalorisation des minimum
de pension ça c'est une ça c'est une
réalité factuelle qu'il faut dire on
réduit l'écart effectivement sur le
temps de cotisation pour bénéficier de
la retraite à terme votre chroniqueur
l'a très bien dit ce sera quatre mois
d'écart toujours plus pour pour les
hommes il y a une chose qui sera pas
réduite je le dis quand même en passant
c'est une réalité aussi par rapport au
comportement et à des causes de santé
publique que l'espérance de vie à la
retraite des femmes et 4 ans de plus que
celle des hommes mais cette réforme va
faire converger les choses entre le
niveau de pension entre les hommes et
les femmes et effectivement la durée de
cotisations
c'est de dire que c'est de dire qu'on
fait converger la durée de cotisations
par rapport à la pension c'est assez
logique en fait
c'est une visionne à la société
particulière que nous nous partageons
pas alors d'une part vous n'avez cessé
de dire jusqu'à présent alors maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est un peu compliqué de
tordre les chiffres qu'il y a un effet
dans l'étude d'impact mais il y a
quelques jours même encore aujourd'hui
Elisabeth borne continue à le dire je ne
sais pas comment c'est possible que les
femmes étaient gagnantes normalement
avec cette réforme aujourd'hui on voit
avec les chiffres après vous pouvez en
inventer d'autres mais quand même là les
chiffres non les femmes sont perdantes
avec cette réforme surtout sur la
pension minimale on va en parler oui
mais la peinture
aussi il existe aujourd'hui aussi c'est
pour des carrières complètes donc il y
en a pas beaucoup qui font quand même
des carrières complètes et celles qui
n'ont pas de carrière complète
continueront à toucher des sommes en
dessous du minima en tout cas en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté quoi qu'il en soit
aujourd'hui
on a fait le gouvernement avait dit ça
fait deux quinquennat qui dit l'égalité
salariale l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes sera la grande cause
nationale à part que au niveau de
l'activité il y a toujours un écart de
48% entre les femmes et les hommes au
niveau de la rémunération ça on le sait
c'est comme ça ça ne se résorbe pas
toutes les politiques que vous avez
menées non seulement à une résorbe pas
ces inégalités mais parfois elle les a
grandi parce qu'il y a eu d'autres
réformes qui ont eu un impact négatif
sur sur les femmes parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont quand même les femmes qui sont
en situation les plus précaires qui sont
dans les métiers les moins payés les
filières à prédominance féminine sont
les moins payés les femmes c'est celles
qui sont le plus atteints partiel et au
niveau du dérange pour financer le
système de d'une certaine façon en effet
vous l'avez dit les carrières les plus
hachées sont donc pour les femmes donc à
partir de ce fait là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui déjà la différence de
pension entre les femmes et les hommes
et de 48% donc soit on essaye de
résorber ces inégalités mais pour les
résorber il faut certainement pas
reporter l'âge du départ à la retraite
puisque là pour le coup ça continue ça
continue en tout cas à préserver si on
peut avoir ce mot-là malheureusement les
inégalités et encore moins en augmentant
la durée de cotisation déjà ce qu'il
aurait pu être fait c'est enlever la
décote parce que ça c'est
particulièrement pénalisant pour les
femmes alors enlever la décote
annulé l'âge de d'annulation de la
décote à 67 ans c'est ça qu'il n'y ait
plus de décote ça n'a pas toujours
existé la déco c'est à dire que lorsque
vous avez votre année votre durée de
cotisation vous permet de partir avec
un taux plein et bien vous vous n'avez
pas besoin d'avoir une déco c'est à dire
qu'on vous enlève sur votre rémunération
quand même si vous n'arrivez vous
détourner avec la durée de cotisation
sans report de l'âge légal c'est ça non
mais déjà nous on est favorable à un
départ à la retraite à 60 ans
milliards d'euros qu'il faudrait et nous
on avait propositions les femmes
précisément
ces différences entre le système actuel
et le nouveau système sur ces
générations ciblées dans l'étude
d'impact 70 80 c'est très simple déjà
comme je le disais plus vous allongez la
durée de cotisation et plus vous
reportez l'âge de départ à la retraite
et plus c'est pénalisant pour les femmes
donc il faut raccourcir durée de
cotisation comme à un moment donné
c'était le cas on était quand même à 37
ans et demi à un moment donné d'une part
vous voudriez une durée moins longue et
bien les femmes
tout le monde pour tout le monde mais
puisque les femmes ont des carrières
plus âgées que les hommes si vous
rallongez la durée de cotisation ça
pénalise d'autant plus les personnes qui
ont des carrières hachées ensuite vous
revalorisez les métiers après dominance
féminine c'est à dire que vous vous
résorbez les 28% des cas entre les
salaires parce ça aussi ça a un impact
sur le niveau des pensions forcément si
vous avez des salaires plus bas vous
avez des pensions pubstes ça c'est
évident aussi donc ça vous devez faire
ce travail qui n'est pas fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que il y a
toujours ses 28% de différence corriger
déjà les inégalités de la société pour
qu'elle ne serait-ce pas sur les 25
meilleures années qui n'étaient pas
toujours été les cas il faudrait revenir
sur un calcul sur les 10 meilleurs
années parce que ça aussi lorsque vous
revenez public privé au 25 meilleures
années ça a pénalisé particulièrement
les femmes alors il y a beaucoup de
sujets s'il vous plaît
répondez rapidement mais je voudrais
quand même vous montrer un petit
reportage après sur les carrières parce
que je voudrais pas qu'on dise des
choses inexactes on est dans un système
à durée de cotisation il faut 43 années
pour avoir la retraite à taux plein il y
a pas de problème on peut la baiser à
avoir cotisation oui déclencher votre
pension aujourd'hui à 62 ans
progressivement vers demain 64 ans sauf
les carrières longues etc bon mais
vous avez à 67 ans un âge d'annulation
c'est-à-dire que quand bien même non non
mais c'est ça parce que vous avez dit
Monsieur
67 ans
à 67 ans que vous ayez fait ou non votre
trimestre vous avez une place et ça ça
favorise ce qui les femmes qui ont les
Karachi une femme qui sont les personnes
qui vont à 65 ans aujourd'hui s'il vous
plaît
vous inspire comme commentaire déjà
Nicole Bachard c'est intéressant vous
êtes un peu la citoyenne à la place du
téléspectateur qui s'interroge face à ce
débat exactement ça m'inspire de choses
d'abord peut-être rappeler que le fait
que les femmes reçoivent des trimestres
de cotisations
supplémentaires parce que pour le fait
qu'elles font élève des enfants c'est
pas ça c'est fondamental de se rappeler
peut-être que c'est pas de la charité
c'est avoir des enfants c'est absolument
crucial pour faire tourner la société
faire tourner les l'économie les femmes
sont pénalisées à l'arrivée je vous
apprends rien du tout mais puisque
évidemment c'est pas simplement qu'il
leur carrière est attachée c'est que
réintégrer son poste après dans la
plupart des métiers c'est extrêmement
difficile et que dans les par exemple
dans les postes très compétitifs les
femmes qui ont des enfants elles sont
quand même poussé sur le côté vers
quelque chose d'un peu plus tranquille
et qu'ils amènera moins loin donc c'est
normal qui a un système de compensation
au niveau de la retraite maintenant moi
je voudrais vous rendre service d'une
certaine manière
il sortait de ce système de
communication vous ajoutez des pommes et
des oranges c'est à dire si vous dites
c'est une question de justice on va
essayer de réparer les injustices tout
le monde doit travailler toujours plus
longtemps on n'est pas forcé d'être de
votre avis mais on vous suit quand vous
dites
les femmes qui ont des petites pensions
ça va être revalorisées donc c'est une
justice de l'autre côté elles vont
travailler plus longtemps
c'est pas un problème c'est pas
compenser il y a une injustice dans la
durée que vous répétez par la meilleure
vous allez répondre mais je voudrais
quand même c'est ça tout simplement sur
la question de la durée non c'est pas
c'est pas juste vous allez répondre vous
êtes un peu minorité sur ce plateau faut
le reconnaître je voudrais quand même
vous montrer vous gardez les questions
en tête vous montrer ce reportage sur
les carrières hachées ou incomplètes
Verbatim témoignage de femmes
recueillies par Baptiste garguic
Chartier
aux yeux du gouvernement elles sont les
gagnants de cette réforme des retraites
pourtant les femmes aux carrières
hessori majoritairement impactés par le
nouveau système mais de quoi s'agit-il
une carrière haché est une alternance
entre emploi chômage et inactivité d'où
la difficulté de cotiser tout au long
d'une carrière pour arriver à une
retraite à taux plein si la réforme
passe les carrières longues et linéaires
seraient donc moins touchées mais alors
pourquoi les femmes sont-elles les plus
concernées 80% étant partielle c'est du
travail féminin donc ça sera
essentiellement des femmes et des femmes
qui sont souvent des mères isolés et qui
n'ont pas n'ont pas pu reprendre le
travail pour s'occuper de leurs enfants
illustration devant cette école primaire
où les retraites font l'objet de toutes
les attentions
à la retraite donc je trouve ça injuste
pour plus tard bah là ça fait un que je
suis à temps partiel à 50% et je compte
rester deux ans encore à 50% pour être
vu mon fils mais ça va être compliqué
pour plus tard quoi et vous attend
parce qu'avec les nouvelles lois je sais
pas trop comment ça va passer
normalement oui j'ai déjà tout mes
trimestres mais le problème c'est
qu'elle est pas assez élevée ma retraite
donc il faut que je continue
alors une revalorisation est-elle prévue
selon les données du corps 28% des
femmes étaient à temps partiel en 2021
contre 8 chez les hommes pour les
français n'ayant pas de retraite à taux
plein revalorisation prévue au prorata
de leur carrière en clair les femmes
concernées pourront compter en moyenne
sur 53 € de plus par mois pour les
petites retraites
voilà on en vient donc à la question de
la pension minimale elle y tient
beaucoup Isabelle borne elle a martelé
aux questions au gouvernement ce sont
les femmes les plus modestes qui ont ces
carrières hachées qui vont en bénéficier
c'est les deux tiers de des concernés
c'est ça l'idée 1200 euros net ou déjà
ça c'est une avancée donc sur la pension
minimale c'est une brique d'universalité
je peux vous dire que les agriculteurs
dans ma circonscription et voient cette
mesure de manière très favorable d'avoir
un écart significatif entre aussi le
minimum vieillesse c'est ce qu'on
appelle le minimum contributif quand
vous avez travaillé toute votre vie le
jour de la liquidation vous aurez 85 %
du SMIC net au jour de la liquidation ça
c'est une avancée considérable ça
correspond à 1200 euros brut sur lequel
s'applique
il faut le préciser
parce qu'il a dit les choses
dit très bien les choses les femmes ont
effectivement plus de temps partiel et
plus de cariérarchie ça c'est une
réalité c'est un sujet de fond c'est un
combat de société que nous menons
là-dessus
minimale si elles n'ont pas le temps les
trimestres
donc ça c'est un fait donc si c'est
justement c'est à dire que la pension
minimale
vous avez des femmes et une réalité
aujourd'hui de du marché du travail
actuel où les femmes sont effectivement
moins payés je veux dire or fonction
publique ont plus de temps partiel et
ont des carrières hachées donc dans les
au niveau de revenus à la retraite où
les a vous les retrouvez sur les
pensions les plus basses et donc elles
vont bénéficier proportionnellement
beaucoup plus de cette valorisation il y
a une chose quand même
super entendre Sandrine Rousseau un peu
moins parlé jusqu'à présent Sandrine
Rousseau sur les pensions minimum qui
vont concerner les femmes donc ça va
revaloriser leur pension non mais il y a
un calcul qui a été fait par Mediapart
sur les 1200 euros qui est l'argument
phare du gouvernement
48 personnes seront concernées par ces
1200 euros 48 personnes en France
pourquoi pourquoi simplement 48 pourquoi
parce qu'il faut avoir eu une carrière
complète au SMIC sans jamais eu avoir un
seul euro d'augmentation donc en fait ça
n'existe pas c'est-à-dire que c'est un
argument qui est un fake absolu et par
ailleurs je rappelle que sur les femmes
il n'y a pas que la question de du
décalage de de l'âge de départ il y a
aussi deux autres choses qui sont
complètement masquées dans le dans le
débat actuel et qui sont très
importantes c'est la reconnaissance des
critères de pénibilité et le travail
haché en journée c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
si vous regardez les femmes et
particulièrement celles qui travaillent
dans l'aide à domicile et bien elles
font une heure chez un chez une personne
puis après elles font deux heures chez
une autre puis une heure
un peu plus fortement mais effectivement
il faut qu'elles aient leur durée toutes
leurs annuités donc là où 43 la limite
quand même oui mais ça limite quand même
le nombre parce que du coup ça peut
faire laisser entendre
9% de la part des gagnants dans la
refonte des minima de pension une
augmentation moyenne de 463 euros
ça toucherait tout le monde non
effectivement ça touche un certain
nombre de personnes et après sur le
l'idée qui est de dire que le l'argument
du gouvernement qui dit regardez les
pensions des femmes vont augmenter avec
la réforme l'étude d'impact elle est
extrêmement claire le montant de la
pension va progresser en moyenne pour
les femmes à partir de 1967 j'ai les
chiffres sous les yeux de 2,2% en
moyenne pour les hommes effectivement
c'est plus bas
09%. le différentiel vous voyez je mets
encore une fois c'est lié au fait que
les salaires des femmes augmentent il
faut s'en féliciter c'est pas la réforme
avec une mesure spécifique on est bien
d'accord deux choses à préciser
là-dessus c'est qu'il y a des écarts de
rémunération dans la vie entre les
hommes et les femmes le système de
retraite corrige ça vous allez pas me
démentir là dessus corrige les cas les
la retraite si on fait le solde de
toutes les inégalités au moment où on
prend la retraite on fait la somme
totale de toutes les inégalités qu'on a
subi tout au long de des caractères des
femmes et des carrières des hommes et
c'est pour ça que les hommes à la
retraite gagnent 67 % de plus que les
femmes alors que dans le dans le monde
actif au moment où ils sont actifs la
différence est de 22% s'il y a que les
femmes gagnent 22 % de moins que les
hommes et donc là c'est faux donc on
peut pas laisser dire ça de pension et
inférieur
les services vérifieront est-ce que
l'écart de pension versus l'écart de
rémunération dans la vie ok juste deux
choses
on a parlé un peu de la pension minimale
sur les carrières acheter qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans cette réforme quand vous
ne pouvez pas travailler et on n'a pas
parlé pour des raisons très diverses
alors on n'a pas parlé suffisamment de
carrière arrachées et ni des carrières
longues parce que je vous dis que non
seulement maintien est carrément
historique on améliore le dispositif ça
concerne les femmes précisément les
parents mais ça va concerner peut-être
davantage les femmes de d'accorder des
droits aux aidants familiaux pas
seulement quand vous êtes en ligne
directe de génération et lorsque vous
avez vous interrompez pour congés
parental donc en plus du droit actuel je
rappelle qui accorde 8 trimestres par
enfant dans la réforme à venir le
dispositif carrière longue sera amélioré
des trimestres prises en compte avec le
congé en même temps la maternité
déjà pris en compte il est sont un peu
plus pris en compte mais c'est déjà pris
et uniquement uniquement sur la durée de
cotisation et pas sur le calcul de la
retraite donc en fait c'est quand même
mis ce que vous pouvez me répondre sur
les carrières hachées que ce soit une
aide-soignante que ce soit
une personne qui fait le ménage tout ça
c'est des horaires très très différents
que ce soit tout simplement une personne
qui n'a pas d'autre choix que de
s'arrêter pour différentes raisons
d'élever ses enfants est-ce qu'il y a
une mesure spécifique quand vous n'avez
pas pu travailler de façon complète
qui n'a pas les trimestres aujourd'hui
dans le système ce sont les personnes
qui s'arrêtent le plus jusqu'à 67 ans ce
sont ces carrières hachées et donc dans
cette réforme et ça va concerner une
femme sur cinq cet âge d'annulation de
la décote n'est pas bougé je pense quand
même que ça c'est un élémentaire
non mais vous dites n'est pas bouger les
inégalités vous êtes elles devront
travailler
plus longtemps il est sur de la
formation c'est la durée de cotisations
c'est à dire que voilà
de 2013 qui est accéléré donc en vérité
non génération 65 générations 67 sont
les plus impactés à trois trimestres de
plus soyez un homme ou une femme est-ce
que le texte peut être enrichi c'est le
mot qu'utilise Gabriel Attal on a parlé
notamment de cette question des femmes
la génération 70-80 est-ce que ça
pourrait bouger ou c'est figé le débat
parlementaire commence à peine hier le
texte a été présenté au Conseil des
ministres il est présenté à la
commission des finances ce vendredi à la
commission des affaires sociales la
semaine prochaine et deux semaines on
sert à quoi sinon d'accord
précis sur l'avantage pour maternité
entre guillemets c'est très très
compliqué de le changer avec le coup
près de l'âge en fait donc qu'est-ce que
ce serait bonifié encore plus d'être
trimestre dire une dizaine de trimestres
par enfant
je pense que le gouvernement peut-être
va se pencher parce que la difficulté
pour lui aujourd'hui c'est que ça touche
sur deux piliers du macronisme c'est
l'égalité homme-femme et c'est la valeur
travail finalement ce sont les femmes
qu'on fait des enfants et qui
travaillent qui sont les plus pénibles
vous l'aurez compris on va regarder de
très très près cette question des femmes
dans la réforme des retraites le débat à
l'Assemblée vous le savez commence le 6
février prochain dans l'hémicycle merci
ces techniques mais c'est très
concernant il faut prendre le temps
d'essayer de comprendre ce dossier merci
à vous merci d'être venu sur le plateau
de LCP vous restez avec moi nicole
Bacharan dans une dizaine de minutes
exactement les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir les hormoncelles se
demandent si ça va encore la peine de se
battre pour le PS après le spectacle
affligeant de son congrès va revenir sur
la situation au Burkina Faso plus proche
que jamais de la rupture avec la France
et puis une motion référendaire dans la
chronique d'Elsa mondingueva vous saurez
tout dans Bourbon Express mais d'abord
on va parler de Ginette Guy on va parler
de la plus résistante de toutes Nicole
Bachard votre mère c'est le titre de
votre récit bouleversant chez Stock
pourquoi il fallait raconter cette
histoire son histoire et pourquoi
maintenant on en parle juste après
l'invitation de Marion Becker
si on vous invite nicole Bacharan c'est
pour se plonger dans le destin
bouleversant d'une femme amoureuse et
courageuse votre mère la plus résistante
de toutes vous retracez dans ce roman
son engagement dans l'un des plus grands
réseaux de la Résistance
occupé dès novembre 42 Toulouse entre
immédiatement résistance une multitude
de groupes clandestins d'origine
diverses voit le jour
nicole Bacharan vous êtes politologue
spécialiste de la société et de la
politique américaine vous intervenez et
collaborer dans différents médias en
tant que consultant sur ces sujets
auxquels vous avez consacré de nombreux
ouvrages cette fois vous cheminez sur
les traces de votre mère Ginette Guy sur
l'histoire de son amour pendant la
guerre avec Jean Oberman le jeune juif
flamboyant pour qui elle affronta tant
de danger à Toulouse et vous raconter
son engagement dans la Résistance à 18
ans une période sombre dont elle vous a
transmis une valeur la valeur la plus
forte que même inculquée et ma mère
c'est la liberté et la liberté c'est un
concept qui peut être très flou on peut
y mettre toutes sortes de choses dedans
mais quand on l'a perdu on sait
exactement ce que c'est et moi j'essaie
une toute petite Michel de travailler à
la défense de ses valeurs cette liberté
votre mère l'a perdu le 17 juillet 1944
arrêté par la Gestapo à Marseille
interrogé certainement brutalement vous
avez enquêté et reconstitué son parcours
retrouvez les aveux de l'un des pires
tortionnaires de l'époque qui a mené les
interrogatoires de Ginette il qualifie
ainsi votre mère elle fut la plus
résistante de toutes condamnée pour
terrorisme et déportés elle s'enfuira
sur le chemin des camps c'est cette
histoire héroïque dans laquelle vous
vous êtes plongé un émouvant hommage à
votre mère qui a payé si cher le prix de
son engagement
à la lecture de ce livre on se pose une
question nicole Bacharan pourquoi
réaliser ce travail de mémoire
aujourd'hui
c'est vrai pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
quel déclic vous a fait passer à
l'écriture le déclic c'est qu'à un
moment on se dit je suis la seule qui
connaissait cette histoire cette
histoire individuelle
il y a plus personne dans la famille qui
puisse le raconter et j'ai toujours
voulu l'écrire 30 ans que je sais que je
veux écrire ce livre donc à un moment on
se dit ben il faut y aller sinon ça sera
jamais fait il y a une peur aussi de ne
pas lui rendre assez bien justice je
crois que c'est essentiellement ça qui
m'a retenu la peur de pas bien savoir le
faire mais vous le faites très bien il
fallait aussi affronter ce qu'elle a
vécu parce qu'on sent que voilà sortir
aussi d'une forme de déni dans lequel la
fille que vous êtes avait besoin de se
protéger et donc aller voir aller voir
des choses de près la dimension la plus
dure de sa vie de résistante sous
l'Occupation elle en avait pas beaucoup
parlé voire jamais Ginette non jamais
jamais c'est vrai que ma mère elle était
très très ouverte elle parlait des
choses avec beaucoup de facilité
elle n'en faisait pas une affaire si
j'ose dire de cette vie dans la
résistance elle faisait partie de ces
gens qui trouvaient qu'ils avaient
vraiment rien fait d'extraordinaire à
aucun à aucun niveau mais quand même
elle m'avait raconté des choses au fil
des conversations et notamment le fait
qu'elle avait été arrêtée interrogée par
le patron de la Gestapo de Marseille qui
était un personnage éminemment
redoutable on va le voir
exactement elle m'avait raconté chef de
la Gestapo à Marseille
pour sauver sa peau c'est-à-dire faire
la petite gamine niaise qui ne savait
rien sur rien et puis essayer de le
circonvenir de le retourner de mais elle
m'avait pas raconté ce qui s'était passé
physiquement c'est pour ça que vous êtes
allé rechercher dans les archives vous
êtes reparti à Marseille d'ailleurs dans
cet endroit très fantomatique qui était
siège de la Gestapo à Marseille on va
parler d'elle d'abord pour bien
comprendre qu'elle était
qui jeune femme née en 1924 qui vit dans
l'Aude d'origine modeste brillante à qui
tout est promis qui fait des études et
puis qui avec la guerre doit partir à
Toulouse pour travailler et c'est là
qu'elle va faire des rencontres elle va
travailler dans une manufacture de
fourrure et qu'elle va rencontrer un
homme en particulier absolument elle est
quand elle est partie à Toulouse à 18
ans elle
ignorait totalement ce que ça signifie
être juif ou ne pas être juif d'ailleurs
même comme je pense beaucoup de Juifs de
France
n'avaient pas de raison particulière de
se sentir plus juif ou que les
catholiques enfin disons des catholiques
ou des protestants ou autres mais elle
s'est trouvé plongée à Toulouse dans un
milieu complètement juif elle a été donc
témoin au fur et à mesure que le filet
se resserrait des brimades des
interdictions des menaces des
disparitions et elle rencontre et elle
est tombée follement amoureuse d'un
jeune homme magnifique
flamboyant Jean Oberman à qui elle va
sauver la vie
et dans des circonstances complètement
rocambolesque vraiment et ça a été le
grand amour de sa vie donc autant elle
parlait peu des souffrances qu'elle
avait endurées n'en parlait même pas du
tout autant elle parlait très volontiers
de son grand amour de jeunesse ce qui
est frappant c'est qu'en fait elle lui
sauve la vie il y a cette histoire
d'emprisonnement de quartier de Quartier
Juifs quartiers des français elle va
réussir à faire en sorte qu'il soit
emprisonné dans le bon quartier mais
elle a perdu le contact après et elle va
continuer c'est là que c'est l'héroïsme
à l'état brut c'est à dire que ce n'est
plus lié à quelque chose de personnel
elle va entrer dans la Résistance est-ce
que vous avez compris ce point de
bascule oui je pense qu'on était dans un
moment
de répression extrême le printemps 44
c'est vraiment le chaque jour la
répression se durcit les déportations se
multiplient et c'est insupportable et
une fois qu'elle a mis Jean à l'abri
dans une manière extrêmement
particulière mais à l'abri néanmoins
elle dessine d'y aller à fond elle entre
dans un réseau de résistance libération
entre Toulouse le sud de Lyon Marseille
la plus résistante de toutes alors il
faut expliquer ce titre puisque c'est
c'est elle c'est le dossier 27 de la
Gestapo la femme Guy c'est ce qui a
écrit dans le dossier c'est elle entre
guillemets la plus résistante de toutes
et c'est ce SS allemand qui prononce
cette phrase
de toutes les femmes de ce dossier donc
la phrase entière mais sachant ce qu'on
subit les personnes arrêtées dans un
certain très large coup de filet dans
lequel elle a été c'est vrai que cette
phrase je l'ai retrouvé très tard aux
archives des Bouches-du-Rhône puisque le
SS donc garder l'âge a été arrêté
interrogée et donc il y a eu un procès
donc il a été interrogé sur toutes les
personnes qui étaient mentionnées dans
les rapports qu'il avait lui-même écrit
et que la Gestapo n'avait pas eu le
temps de brûler mais c'est vrai que
elle est terrible cette phrase parce
qu'on sait qu'il a prononce et donc on
imagine ce que ce tortionnaire lui a
fait subir c'est un gouffre pour
vraiment le sentiment d'un gouffre qui
s'ouvrait sous mes pieds en même temps
c'est une phrase qui dit tout de son
courage
la plus résistante de toutes on vous dit
moi je savais que ma mère était
courageuse elle le savait pas mais moi
je le savais et
mais ça ça me disait
non ça me faisait soupçonner l'horreur
l'horreur de ce qui s'était passé quand
vous dites moi je le savais pourtant
vous l'avez perdu il y a longtemps vous
l'avez perdu 30 ans comment on fait pour
se mettre dans sa peau parce que vous
vous ne racontez pas votre relation à
elle vous êtes très pudique dans ce
livre c'est raconter comme dans un roman
même si tout est vrai vous racontez son
histoire comment on fait pour réussir ça
il y avait une très grande intimité
entre ma mère et moi c'était pas
difficile pour moi de me mettre dans
dans ma tête mais c'est vrai que ces
jours-ci dans sa tête dans cette voyelle
au docteur froide quand diriez-vous
est-ce qu'on sent que vous vous avez
longtemps voulu la protéger toujours
voulu la protéger donc je savais non je
savais pas je sentais
qui avait une blessure très profonde
dont j'ignorais la profondeur et la
nature et c'est vrai qu'en parlant avec
d'autres personnes qui qui revenaient de
cette époque-là
on se rend compte simplement que
personne n'en revient jamais tout à fait
et qu'en général on en parle pas elle va
réussir
à échapper au camp on va pas raconté
toute l'histoire mais elle sera quand
même déportée elle va prendre un train
pour da chaud je laisse le lecteur
découvrir la suite de l'histoire vous
lui devez votre passion pour l'Amérique
racontez-nous parce qu'elle avait mes
chevilles au cœur une adoration pour le
libérateur Legia qui ont défilé sur les
chars après le débarquement et c'est
vrai que dans ce livre en fait tout est
vrai
mais les deux pages je crois qui
concernent le moment où elle assiste à
la Libération où elle va accueillir les
Américains à l'ouest de Paris sur la
route de Versailles c'est vraiment des
phrases entières qu'elle m'a dit et
qu'elle m'a répété c'est à dire qu'elle
a vu ce contraste incroyable entre les
armées d'occupation avec les bottes
ferrées qui martelaient les pavés et
puis l'arrivée de ces garçons
magnifiques et qui embrassait tout le
monde et qui distribuait des chocolats
et que sais-je et c'était la liberté et
par la suite elle n'a jamais pensé que
l'Amérique était le pays idéale à aucun
moment mais elle nous avait inculqué à
nous ces filles que vraiment si tout
allait mal il y avait un dernier recours
pas forcément le premier choix mais il y
avait un dernier recours c'était
l'Amérique est-ce que on en est là
encore un peu aujourd'hui d'une certaine
façon ce livre il interroge sur le
courage qu'est-ce qu'on ferait si la
guerre arrivait avec la tête qu'est-ce
que je serai moi dans tout ça quand on
voit les images de l'Ukraine là on a
pris une une image terrible des derniers
bombardements Pro vous trouvez que
l'Europe est à la hauteur de ce conflit
je pense que pour l'instant oui moi je
fais partie des gens qui pensent qu'ils
font envoyer
des chars des missiles l'ont portés des
avions parce que la lumière Poutine ne
cèdera pas ce que l'Allemagne a
finalement décidé par faire par
l'intermédiaire de la Pologne avec les
chalets aux parents et je pense que
c'est la notre liberté nos valeurs qui
sont en qui sont en jeu et vous restez
Optimus pour ces valeurs quand on voit
le poids de chez giping le poids de
Poutine dans le monde est-ce que ça vous
fait peur ces attaques la démocratie et
la liberté extrêmement peur mais je
pense qu'on a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix du désespoir c'est du visuel qui
disait ça et on n'a pas le choix de
renoncer à la lutte on n'a pas le choix
de renoncer à nos valeurs vous le voyez
bien les Ukrainiens on leur dit certains
leur disent ben il faudrait peut-être
quand même négocier ils savent que s'il
négocie ils vont mourir donc ils
préfèrent tenter de gagner la guerre
mais voilà on comprend mieux aujourd'hui
selon cheminement de la fille de Ginette
Guy à la politologue Hist des Etats-Unis
Nicole Bachard la plus résistante de
toutes c'est à dire chez Stock tout de
suite les cartes blanches de nos
affranchis ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite
installez-vous mes chers affranchis les
hachez un bon sel fondatrice du podcast
popopole qui va revenir sur les déboires
du Parti socialiste Vincent je grand
reporter le Burkina Faso nous met à la
porte nous Français mais on commence
avec l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est le bourbon Express comme chaque
soir et ce soir il nous est raconté par
vous et à mon dingava une motion
référendaire se prépare késako et bien
écoutez je vais tout vous expliquer je
vais vous raconter l'histoire en fait de
deux objets qui ont beaucoup compté
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée le règlement
de l'Assemblée nationale on commence à
bien le connaître et la calculatrice je
peux vous dire qu'à mon avis ça a
beaucoup servi je vous explique on le
sait les oppositions elles vont tout
faire pour faire reculer le gouvernement
sur cette réforme des retraites ils ont
donc étudié bien toutes les possibilités
de ce règlement de l'Assemblée nationale
ce matin la nupesse annonce avoir déposé
vous l'avez dit une motion référendaire
c'est l'article 122 du règlement il faut
qu'elle soit signée par 58 députés il
faut que les signataires soient présents
dans le moment du vote et si elle est
adoptée à la majorité simple elle va au
Sénat si le Sénat adopte cette
proposition elle se retrouve sur le
bureau du président de la république
libre à lui de faire ce qu'il veut avec
alors ils ne sont pas allés chercher
l'idée bien loin les communistes ils
avaient fait exactement la même chose en
2020 lors de la précédente réforme des
retraites regardez cette archive
les t-shirts alors à l'époque en 2020 la
motion elle avait été discutée dans
l'hémicycle rejeté 70 voix pour 160 voix
contre sauf que là la donne politique à
l'Assemblée nationale a changé
exactement Myriam elle a bien changé
c'est à ce moment-là que cette
calculatrice rentre en jeu on a beaucoup
de moyens regardez effectivement la
donne politique elle est plus la même la
majorité elle est composée trois groupes
à l'Assemblée Renaissance modèle et
horizon au total ça fait 249 députés les
oppositions si on agrège et bien toute
la nupesse le rassemblement national qui
se dit prêt à voter cette motion
référendaire ainsi que le plus petit
groupe liotte ça fait
256 vous avez bien lu Myriam ça veut
dire que mathématiquement et bien il est
possible que cette motion référendaire
passe attention énormément de précaution
il faudrait que tout le monde soit là et
que tous les groupes votent de façon
homogène et puis vous me regardez je
vois bien que vous l'avez remarqué
Myriam il manque un petit peu quelqu'un
il manque la droite les républicains il
pourrait se retrouver mais aussi en
arbitre sur cette réforme des retraites
et sur cette notion référendaire alors
on leur a demandé ce qui comptait faire
regardez la motion référendaire de la
nuque est-ce que vous pourriez la voter
on a on a une position commune aussi là
dessus ce matin on en a discuté enfin du
moment où le Parlement est saisi sur un
sujet aussi important que la réforme des
retraites c'est quand même assez
malvenu de se dessaisir d'un texte aussi
important et de dire finalement renvoie
au référendum donc non le groupe ne
votera pas la motion référendaire
la croisée quelques députés de droite
qui nous disaient qu'ils étudieraient
toutes les bobines les possibilités au
moment venu en ce moment à chaque fois
qu'on croise un député droit de c'est
une ligne horreur différente alors elle
a peu de chance d'aboutir cette notion
puisque quand bien même elle serait
votée ici il faudrait l'accord du Sénat
mais quand même ça dit quelque chose ça
dit quelque chose sur l'avertissement
des oppositions au gouvernement on en a
encore eu une preuve tout à l'heure lors
des questions au gouvernement
et je le dis aux oppositions si nous
sommes intelligents ensemble dans cette
émission nous ferons piller le
gouvernement
je te remercie monsieur le ministre
alors on verra si les oppositions se
mettent en coalition pour faire plier ce
gouvernement une nouvelle arme pour
s'opposer à la réforme essayez de
déclencher un référendum dans le pays
par cette motion j'ai tout compris Léa
on enchaîne vous voulez revenir sur les
heures peu glorieuses du Parti
socialiste après les votes de leur
congrès en effet quel spectacle quand
même digne d'une tragédie grecque je
pense qu'on peut bien le dire le sortant
Olivier Faure qui revendique la victoire
alors que les résultats sont quand même
contestés de la part de son principal
opposant Nicolas Meyer Rossignol et moi
je me suis demandé une question qui
m'empêche un peu de dormir mais pourquoi
on se bat encore pour le Parti
socialiste alors question existentielle
ce soir en effet et oui parce que qui
aurait pu imaginer que finalement on
allait se battre pour un parti qui a
quand même perdu ce n'est pas rien le
enfin les trois quarts de ces adhérents
et adhérents en l'espace de un tout
petit peu plus de 10 ans et un parti il
faut bien le dire qui a fait un score
vraiment
médiocre à la dernière présidentielle et
médiocre est quand même un terme assez
sympathique je trouve
est-ce qu'on peut se poser la question
de savoir est-ce que c'est parce que le
parti est en train de perdre des sièges
plus les années passent plus les chats
de surface et puis il perdent le siège à
l'Assemblée nationale non c'est une
mauvaise réponse il faut plutôt regarder
du côté des institutions territoriales
ou là on se rend compte que certes le PS
est en perte de vitesse et d'influence
au niveau national mais ce n'est pas
tout à fait le cas au niveau local
puisque le parti a encore plus d'une
vingtaine de conseils départementaux il
dirige aussi et président quatre régions
sur 17 il est aussi à la tête de plus de
50 communes de 30 000 habitants qui par
conséquent fait de cette force politique
la principale force politique de gauche
au Sénat avec plus de plus de 60
sénateurs et sénatrices
et il faut bien le dire à gauche aucun
parti n’est en capacité de rivaliser oui
donc bon nous vous dites attention ce
qui disent qu'il est mort c'est pas
complètement vrai qu'est-ce que ça peut
avoir comme conséquence alors les
conséquences c'est qu'en fait
l'implantation territoriale du Parti
socialiste sur lequel il arrive quand
même à bien s'asseoir lui lui attribue
quand même une influence non négligeable
au niveau local qui en fait presque un
acteur incontournable notamment dans les
décisions qui peuvent être prises à
l'avenir sur les scrutins locaux
pourquoi pas avec qui la France
insoumise ou les députés pardon le le
parti europécologie les Verts et ce
qu'on peut constater quand même qui est
assez symptomatique des parties
naissants des parties nouveaux c'est
qu'ils ont quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de mal à s'implanter au niveau
territorial alors je comprends beaucoup
mieux maintenant pourquoi d'un côté
Nicolas Maya Rossignol et Olivier fort
de l'autre autant
on met un peu moins en avant tout n'est
pas complètement mort ou Parti
socialiste comment vous regardez ça vous
vous êtes une femme de gauche ou pas une
école Bachard consterné par l'état du
Parti socialiste je pense qu'on est un
pays qui a besoin d'une opposition et
d'une opposition qui se qui se tiennent
il y a quand même un héritage très fort
très important de de ce parti et là ils
sont quoi il y a 20 000 adhérents
pour 40 000 adhérents seulement ça doit
être mais de réorganiser
que l'héritage le mérite mais les
héritiers j'en suis beaucoup moins sûr
parce que il y a quelque chose de
profondément minable dans ce à quoi on
vient on vient d'assister les
accusations de bourrage d'urne etc et a
fondamentalement de position
incompatibles ne pèse ou pas nupes quand
même là que ça se passe et l'heure de
vérité pour eux n'a pas encore sonné
manifestement faudra attendre on part au
Burkina Vincent c'est un c'est un
ultimatum qui a posé Ouagadougou à la
France c'est ça au mieux c'est un
préavis au pire à un ultimatum va pour
l'ultimatum ce que ça elle vue de France
le pire est toujours sûr ou peut s'en
fout les 400 hommes donc de ces forces
spéciales sabres logées non loin de
Ouagadougou ont donc un mois pour faire
leur pactage puisque la jungle que
dirige le capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré tomber fin septembre d'un
autre pucciste vient de dénoncer
l'accord régissant depuis 4 ans
maintenant la présence militaire
française au Burkina Faso quel paraît
loin l'embellie illusoire de l'été
lorsque Paris proposait un soutien
opérationnel contre le fléau djihadiste
qui ronge et sape le pays des hommes
intègres il était question à l'époque
d'une enveloppe de 15 millions d'euros
pour tout cela est enterré depuis lors
sans fleurs ni couronne donc ça veut
dire que ça y est l'éviction est
inexorable après le Mali le Burkina même
motif même punition déjà au guilh en
neuf Ouaga avait exigé le départ de
l'ambassadeur Luc alade son forfait
avoir constaté la dégradation de la
situation sécuritaire un diagnost
accrédité par tous les experts dignes de
ce nom jeudi dernier une série
d'attaques terroristes à côté la vie à
une trentaine de civils dont une
quinzaine d'ailleurs affiliée aux
volontaires pour la défense de la patrie
c'est une milice supplétive activement
formée médiocrement équipée à minimal la
moitié du Faso échappe au contrôle du
pouvoir de pectoraux lequel doit son
assise incontestable encore aujourd'hui
à sa promesse de vaincre les soudards du
califat on recense depuis 2015 2
millions de déplacés et des milliers
d'écoles fermées et que dire de ces
villes des provinces Nordistes du Soum
et du BAM soumise au blocus des força de
la charia donc ça veut dire que la suite
c'est le Burkina qui va qui va regarder
vers la Russie c'est ça
de leur frère d'armes maliens les
poutches Burkinabés c’étaient à la
chimère moscovite et ils veulent croire
que le Kremlin et ces mercenaires sauce
Wagner feront mieux que l'ancienne
puissance coloniale sans couverture
aérienne stratégie cohérente mercenaire
ou demeurant plus performant dans
l'exaction aveugle et la prédation que
dans la castagne frontale on a vu la
Ouaga comme hier Bamako ou Bangui des
zélotes progintes brandir drapeau russe
et portrait de Vladimir Poutine la
Russie est un choix de raison que les
Ron le Premier ministre Apollinaire qui
élève de tomber là et d'invoquer dans la
foulée un combat pour la souveraineté
pour la souveraineté vraiment à quoi bon
ce délester du joue post-colonial
français c'est pour se jeter dans les
pattes d'un ours qui inflige à l'Ukraine
une agression impérialiste et l'Orne ici
comme ailleurs d'ailleurs sur les
ressources du sous-sol que l'on songe
aux appétits par exemple de la société
aurifère nordgol propriété de
l'oligarque à l'exsei mordachoff Traoré
les siens ni tout contact avec les
chiens de guerre de Prigogine sans
convaincre dès la mi-désembre le
président du Ghana déplorait ainsi la
conclusion d'un arrangement je le cite
Waga Wagner avec session d'une mine d'or
Paris s'apprête donc à rengainer son
fort bien tout État détient le droit
inaliénable de mettre un terme à ces
accords de coopération et c'est heureux
le X c'est que les pactes phostiens que
le Sahel cell avec Moscou ne mèneront
nulle part sinon au dépit à la rancœur
voire le moment venu à la colère le
réveil sera brutal merci Vincent c'est
l'autre tombe en pratique entre les
pattes de Wagner de Poutine et du
Kremlin et comment dire la ça montre
l'efficacité incroyable de la propagande
russe à travers toutes sortes d'actions
et notamment les réseaux sociaux c'est
présent évidemment aux États-Unis on l'a
vu dans plusieurs élections en Allemagne
pour le brexit en France en 2017 et dans
chaque pays africain c'est une puissance
de destruction absolument inimaginable
mais quand il parle de choix de la
raison les Africains c'est glaçant ce
mot là d'utiliser la raison quand on
parle de Poutine Vincent ça semble
fou un partage c'est-à-dire vous avez
des dettes fautes africains totalement
corrompus protégé par des mercenaires
qui n'ont pas de limite à leurs
exactions et qui empoche les ressources
les ressources naturelles comme choix de
la raison c'est admirable
en contact régulier par messagerie
cryptée me disent qu'il se sentent pris
entre le marteau djihadiste et l'enclume
Wagner et le fait qu'il y ait cette
guerre en Ukraine ne fait absolument pas
réagir des Africains enfin en tout cas
Mally Burkina
pour s'apercevoir que la narration russe
a un certain écho tant le ressentiment
vis-à-vis de l'impérialisme
occidental
rencontre les frustrations voir la
détresse de ceux qui ne comprennent pas
que la cinquième armée du monde l'armée
française soit incapable d'éradiquer le
fléaudianiste
une nouvelle forme de guerre froide qui
se profile à nouveau une école assez
chaude je pense que l'Afrique c'est à
nous porte merci beaucoup Nicole
bacharon de nous avoir accompagné dans
cette émission et merci à vous les
affranchis Elsa à très vite la plus
résistante de toutes c'est-à-dire chez
Stock avant de se quitter LCP aimerait
avoir une pensée pour Antoine Bounour
Antoine Bounour nous a quitté il y a
déjà quelques semaines c'était notre
ingénieur du son il travaillait
régulièrement pour cette émission et ses
obsèques avaient lieu aujourd'hui on
pense à sa famille bien évidemment très
belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]